as a writer I was able eventually to buy
a home in La that's not easy to do I
have friends who are creators they have
they just bought their seventh vacation
home and I'm not
exaggerating so here's the difference
between a writer and a Creator a writer
is always chasing a paycheck they're
always looking for a job they're always
looking for someone to hire them and pay
them to write I was a writer and so
here's just one
example the uh movies Studios will hire
writers because they've bought some
Source material maybe the rights to
remake something maybe they bought a
graphic novel they need to hire someone
to write that script or they have an
original idea need to hire someone to
write that script or they have a script
that someone wrote and they it needs
work and they need someone to rewrite it
so these are called feature writing
assignments and that's what I did
for uh I did 19 of them and basically
what happens is they let the industry
know we're looking for a writer at this
budget range for this and the agents and
manager I got the perfect person read
this sample meet with this person and
they make a list and they meet with
people oneon-one and you pitch you pitch
your heart out you're like here's what I
would do here's how to make this great
and and they they can they'll hire
someone and that's what I did for a
living so I'd get paid it was nice money
i' write the project and then when I was
done it was go out and audition for
another job and that was my life always
being a writer always chasing a
paycheck uh I train a lot of TV writers
and obviously for TV writers they are
staff writers you know the TV shows have
rooms of writers and you get hired and
you get a contract and you work for the
year and you get paid and you get
benefits and then when the year's over
you very much hope the show brings you
back and if they don't then you got to
scramble and try to find another show
that's a writer a writer is always
chasing a paycheck not a Creator a
Creator is not chasing a paycheck
they're not looking for someone to
validate them and say okay I'll pay you
a Creator is creating their future they
are not chasing jobs what a Creator is
doing is they're
creating the life that they want I'll
give you some
examples absolute true story there's two
writers Rob and Sharon and they move to
LA now when you come to LA and you don't
have an agent you don't have a manager
you don't have credits it's hard to get
people to notice you it's hard to get
people to read your scripts it can be
done you got to know how to play the
game you have to be uh very dedicated
you have to be relentless it's going to
take some real time and energy you got
to climb that mountain everyone has to
do it it can be done if you know the
right way to do it but it's going to
take time and energy Robin and Sharon
met each other online on Twitter and
they became friends and then they
started collaborating and then they
became writing partners and they both
also were actors so at some point
they're like well we could put a lot of
time and energy to try to get
representation and Chase writing job or
we just create our future what what what
we want to do is write a show like this
and maybe even be in it so now that's
not easy that that there's a lot of
things you have to do to make that
happen I'll talk about it in a little
bit but that's what they did because
they figured it's pretty much the same
Mount it's just different Mountain but
it's it's going to take time and energy
but so is the other option and their
show so and it got made and it was
called catastrophe and they are the
stars of the show and they created their
entire career they created it they
weren't looking for someone to pay them
if you're a writer you are paid to serve
someone else's Creative Vision if you're
a Creator you get to pay writers to
serve your vision so I worked with a
writer uh her name is Jacqueline and she
had a manager and she actually had been
staffed on some shows but it was like
she'd be staffed one year two years she
wasn't then she was then she wasn't so
it was like I have a paycheck I don't
have a paycheck I have a paycheck I
don't have a paycheck living off savings
sometimes have to supplement it with
work it's stressful you you're always
stressed about what is going to happen
in three months and she heard me speak
and she goes will you work with me
because I want to be a Creator I don't
want to be a writer so I read her work I
I knew she had a lot of potential I'm
like okay so what are we going to create
and Jacqueline's like well what what
should I like what is what are they
looking for what could I sell it's like
whoa whoa whoa Jacqueline that's the
writer's mindset that's the what does
mommy and daddy want what does the
industry want uh what do I need to do to
make the industry happy that's not a
Creator mindset the Creator mindset is
what do you want to create what do you
most want to create what is so unique
and inside you that you're willing to
work tirelessly to create so she comes
back she goes I got these three ideas
which one you think has the best chance
whoa whoa whoa Jacqueline that's the
writer's mindset the Creator's mindset
is which one of these three means the
most to you she goes well this one I'm
like why and now the work begins why do
you love this so much why do you love
these characters so much what why is
this so deeply important to you okay so
this is what you're going to put your
effort in this is now your dream this is
now the direction you're marching now
comes the stuff you have to learn like
you have to learn how to heighten the
concept I learned that very early on um
I was a uh a a studio reader a
gatekeeper and my job was to read
scripts and then if I thought a script
was phenomenal to tell my boss hey I
think you should read this so I would
I'd go to I didn't do it very often like
hey this script's amazing like what's
the concept and I had like a minute at
most to pitch it so I'd pitch it and
they're like nah Pasadena that was his
way of saying passing and I'm like but
the script is he's like I don't care the
concept isn't and so it was really
helpful for me I didn't have a career at
the time but I realized okay until
you're an established writer you have to
heighten a concept you have to take your
concept and you have to be able to
heighten it where when someone tells a
decision maker in 30 seconds the concept
they'll be like you I want to read that
so I helped Jacqueline with that I
helped her with story engines you need
to have a story engine to sell anything
because no one buys a pilot script they
want to buy a show and you need without
a a a a long form story engine you can't
sell anything used to be easier because
everything was episodic in network TV
where it was like each week was just a
standalone episode so was episodic
engines but now everything's long form
storytelling so it's like a movie told
over 10 or 20 episodes so you had to
teach her how to do an engine had to
teach her some other uh things like
proof of concept and then we had to work
on the pitch that was so important
because in this Marketplace you want to
be a Creator you write the pilot but you
pitch the show and and people don't
spend enough time on the pitch so she
spent four months working with me and
also working with a uh showrunner friend
and she had an amazing pitch she had an
amazing script and I also had her do a
lookbook and a lookbook it was like a 25
uh page book that just
visually showed you what this could be
and really made you in an immersive way
feel like this was a show now that's a
lot of work I mean all in it was a year
it was a lot of work but she's not
chasing a job she's wants to be a
Creator and so it went out and oh I
should say that um her role model was
catastrophe that's why I brought
catastrophe up and her project had a
similar tone and a similar energy but a
very different concept well Sharon has a
production company that's what happens
when you are a Creator you create a
production company Sharon who was the
writer an actor in catastrophe she read
this and loved it and said I'm want to
produce this this is like something I
would have written 20 years ago
Jacqueline's probably about 20 years
younger than her and then it went out
and it sold and um before the strike it
was going to go into production so
hopefully it will go into production
that's what a Creator does I'll give you
another example Leslie and Simon came to
La they didn't know anyone didn't have
representation started looking around
realize how the game is played and it's
like okay this is what you got to do to
get people to notice you and get
meetings it's going to take a long time
take a lot of energy can be
done why don't we just spend the time
and energy being creators and finding
what we want to do and owning it and
developing it and getting the world
excited by our vision two years later
they wrote an academy award-winning film
All Quiet on the Western Front now I've
become really good friends with them
they're awesome people so writers chase
the
opportunities the opportunities Chase
creators so Leslie and Simon now are
putting together a production company
they're not going around auditioning for
jobs they're having dinner with stars
major directors heads of Studios heads
of networks yeah you write an Academy
Award winning film that's what happens
it completely changes your life and I
just want to share something personal
so I don't come from money um my parents
cut me off so I I had no safety net I
was living off Top Ramen and and uh
student loans and I started working and
I was a writer I was chasing the
paychecks and I had fear I I kept
chasing more and more jobs because I
didn't want the pays to end and I had
multiple agents and managers say hey you
got enough money in the bank take a year
off and be a Creator take your shot I
mean yeah being a paid writer is cool
but it isn't here's the thing like why
do you want to be a writer and I ask
someone this why do you want to be a
writer is it you want to share your
story
in your characters with the world you
want to be a Creator do you want
creative freedom you want to be a
Creator if you're in it for the money
you don't have to be ashamed of that if
money matters it mattered to me you want
to be a Creator uh as a writer I was
able eventually to buy a home in La
that's not easy to do I have friends who
are creators they have they just bought
their seventh vacation home and I'm not
exaggerating I I have uh friends or
creators they have three different
vacation homes in Italy I don't know why
they need that but they have I mean
so you want to be a Creator and not a
writer but I was scared I was like I
could spend a year and I could write
this thing from my heart and I could
just do the thing I most want and it
could be
rejected and that that that was that
just felt painful and I'm like no just
just get me a job and just get me a
paycheck also I think partly I I grew up
in a very blue College
household my mom worked retail my dad I
mean they they I love my parents and
um and I never went to bed hungry and
they paid for my undergraduate and I so
I know I was much more fortunate than a
lot of people but they worked for a job
they they they didn't have wealth they
didn't have Investments they don't come
from money they they came from nothing
and they just worked every day for their
paycheck and I had that mentality and um
and I I look back and I really regret
this because like seeing Leslie and
Simon's life it's like what if I had
taken a year off and tried that would I
have succeeded maybe maybe not but at
least I would have tried I never tried I
was just always chasing a paycheck so
you have a choice to make especially if
you're newer on your writing Journey
you're coming into the game at The Best
Time Ever there's going to be U Less
writing jobs um I know it's s like the
best thing ever I'll finish my thought
but without going into details Netflix
and Amazon just had obscene amounts of
money funneled to them from Wall Street
to just make everything that's not going
to happen anymore they're going to be
spending less money there's still going
to be a lot of money spent there's still
going to be a lot of writing jobs out
there but there won't be as many and you
should prepare yourself for that cuz
you're going to hear a lot of stories
about people are like it's impossible I
had a writing job and now I can't you
know the B+ writers were working and now
they probably won't be working so just
you're going to hear a lot of Doom and
Gloom so it's going to get a little
harder to keep getting that writing
paycheck very doable but it's going to
be easier to be a Creator because there
is now going to be more and more outlets
for you and opportunities and resources
and support so you have a
choice
nothing is going to be easy in this life
and nothing's going to be easy in the
entertainment world it's very
competitive you're going to have to pour
heart and soul suffer through a lot of
rejection and you going have to just
keep getting back on your feet and
you're going to have to keep marching
forward but the question is what are you
marching
toward what is your dream your dream is
what you navigate toward you can you is
your dream to just keep getting paid and
have someone pay you as a writer no
shame if that's your dream but at least
consider the alternative right can I
interject from um what if someone
doesn't have the temperament though to
be a Creator I I love what you're saying
and I love the stories that you use um
but what if they don't have the
discipline they can't even show up for
themselves every day but they have this
great story
idea and then B so that's a and then B
the money that it would take to create
something or to sustain someone while
they're trying to create something yeah
great question so well let's start with
the
second
so someone wants to be a writer and
let's say there's two people and one
person's like I want to be a writer I
want to get representation and I want to
get start getting writing paychecks and
this person's like not me I want to be a
Creator okay it's going to take both
these
people a period of time before either of
them see any money so both these people
are going to have to find a way to
sustain themselves so that's
that's just part of the game and and
everyone goes through that I remember
working with a writer and um she's like
she was working as a reader and she was
working for a producer because she was
making connections and learning stuff
and she was making money to live but she
had no energy to write and she decided
what's my dream what's my dream is to be
a Creator so I need to make a living in
a way that gives me the time and energy
to create so she quit she moved back to
her hometown I think it was lanine
Michigan where it was a lot uh cheaper
cost of living and she worked uh as a
she got a manager training program and
became a manager at the Gap and the
reason is she said I stood around and I
folded in fluffed clothing and doing
that I I could work in my head and right
and when I came home I was charged to
work and I did that for a year and I did
my best writing now I I lived a very
modest lifestyle I was in no offense to
Lancing Michigan but her friends were in
La now she wanted to be in La that's the
choice she made so but my point is the
question of how do you support yourself
until you can start to make money exists
either way if you want to be a writer or
a Creator so that's no difference and
I'll answer the the first part which is
what if someone doesn't have the um the
temperament what if someone doesn't have
the discipline and can't be
self-sufficient and show up for
themselves I would say that that person
will not make it as a Creator and they
won't make it as a writer it doesn't
matter that you you you need that for
both and if you don't have that you got
two
choices get another
dream or learn to do that these are
skills that you can train yourself and
don't you know it we can change and if
we want something bad enough but I would
just candidly and bluntly say if someone
is not resourceful thick skinned
hardworking I mean
hardworking uh willing to put the time
in and uh will work for themselves and
and are self-accountable if they don't
have that they're not going to make it
as a writer or a
Creator I'm just curious why thick
skinned I like all the other things
where where does being thick skinn come
in so this is personal to me
because um you know I I've I was a
writer for 10 years that's how I made my
living I I did teach occasionally at
UCLA film school but I was a writer and
then for a variety of reasons I went
from being a writer very excitedly to be
someone who works with writers and helps
writers and I've been doing that for the
last 10 years and being on this side of
the table it's so clear to me that all
writers have strengths weaknesses and
blind spots blind spots are weaknesses
they don't know they
have I had a blind spot I I eventually
realized what it was but it was kind of
late into the game and I didn't know
what to do about it this was my blind
spot so let me step back and talk about
some of my strengths you know I was
incredibly
hardworking uh you know if I put my mind
to something I'll I will just keep going
till I die or succeed I never quit um I
think I'm really good at picking things
up and and finding the people that can
help me and not being and not being so
full of myself that I don't listen and I
think I take notes really well I had
some writing ability so all that's great
but my biggest blind spot was resilience
which I did not have and I would Define
resilience the following
way when things are going your way and
you're getting good news and the
writing's flowing it's easy to show up
every
day and be at your
best but when you get punched in the
face when you get bad news when you get
kicked in the gut and man that's kind of
you know the industry is like a roller
coaster I'd show up because I was but I
was not at my best I I was writing um
from Fear I I was reactive I wasn't
centered I wasn't my best me it wasn't
my best writing and of course this goes
beyond writing I you know um you know
I'm in relationship you know with my
wife when everything's going great I'm a
great husband when I get kicked in the
gut by life I I can sort of go into a
shell and be a little uh edgy and not
always so present I've gotten a lot
better in my older age but as a
writer I put the time in but I wasn't
resilient what resilience is no matter
what's happening to
you you show up and you work at your
best um you know I I'm into like sports
and like when you look at the the best
you know like Steph Curry or Michael
Jordan in
basketball um that's what they have in
Spades they have the ability that no
matter what's going on in their career
the game they always play at their best
they are
resilient um if you rank resilience on a
scale one to 10 I was a very low
number and that
I'm I'm grateful that I had a career in
spite of that I would have had a much
better
career if I could have dealt with it I
didn't realize it till late in the game
and then when I did realize it I didn't
know what to do about it you know I I
read books I talked to people I I didn't
know how to become more resilient until
I stopped writing then I could do it um
so that's why I'm saying thick skin that
was sort of my proxy for um it doesn't
mean that you don't feel pain it doesn't
mean that when you get bad news or
something unfair happens that you don't
go oh that hurts uh or if you get
terrible news about someone you love
something bad is happen to them it's not
like it doesn't affect you it affects
you but when you show up to the keyboard
you
are writing to the best of your ability
that's resilience and the the best
writers who consistently write to the
best of their ability have the best
careers